[Music]
okay so do you want to drive or should I
crazy idea
let's uber no dude that sketches me out
I've never done that before
I've heard it's easy with just tired
[Music]
Hey aah Chauncey mm-hmm okay uh with
this you can take us anywhere yeah
anywhere straight to the Met Gala driver
I love gallows I want to go to Australia
and I will not take no as an answer I
want to go to Milan what do you mean
there isn't a filet mignon drive-through
what about lobster drive-throughs any of
those feel like I'm on a safari but with
people Kirkland what do I look like a
dog easy on the brakes Chauncey I'd hate
to sue your ass for whiplash can't see
what school of driving did you attend
Brown sides being a driver what else do
you do Who am I kidding
I don't care and see I want to live take
it to 100 miles an hour what do you mean
this can't fly you mean this is a hybrid
what do you mean this is a Honda Accord
I found at my Tesla didn't take gasps I
immediately totaled it you know I was
once engaged to a Ford Johnson Denzel
Washington winked at me at a party once
perfect oh she's calling hello Rihanna
are these windows tinted I'd hate for
the paparazzi to catch Oh this
bulletproof I don't want to be Kennedy I
thought lift was an app for plastic
surgery
lord knows Brenda would love to
assassinate me did you know Elizabeth's
husband was having an affair with her
chauffeur again oh I cannot believe I
went 52 years without having a driver
can't believe I used to walk korte do
you have any scissors I need to cut up
my license immediately I feel like the
Pope in the popemobile we are in the
future
I love Hoover goodbye Chauncey ah well
that was so easy oh here he is a
thousand and two dollars what the hell
is a surge price
[Music]